[Applause]
a rapturous welcome for Johnny Depp and
his new film Jean de bahi which opened
the Cannes Film Festival the true tale
of a working-class woman who uses her
beauty to climb the social ladder until
she reaches King Louis XV and falls in
love but causes scandal in the court
it's the story of a free woman ignoring
social codes shot in the Palace of
Versailles an opulent historical drama
sitting down with Al Jazeera Depp said
after two high-profile trials the film
came at a perfect time for him and he
could relate to the scrutiny endured by
his character from the my experiences in
in that kind of
living that kind of complex life
I can only imagine for a king
I mean we can ask the the that his
uh
the pressures I'm afraid to watch me I'm
afraid to shave in the morning because I
have to look at myself
so uh
I haven't seen the film yet but many in
France have the film was simultaneously
screened across hundreds of Cinemas
though some believe it was a
controversial Choice star Johnny Depp
has obviously had his own issues with
the law and also my when the director
has recently had accusations against her
and you know she herself
um she married Luke Besson very young I
wouldn't say she's necessarily engaged
with feminism people have called her
auntie me too my Wen who spent seven
years working on the project draws a
number of parallels with her character
[Music]
temperament her story and her trajectory
maybe because it was a love story that
was highly criticized where she was
insulted maybe because I lived a love
story too which was criticized I wanted
to defend this to defend the idea that
love can exist between a powerful man
and a woman of lower social class it
revolts me that even today we still
think that a woman who comes from a poor
background if she's with a man of power
is there for self-interest can is often
caught in controversy but Festival
director
says he has one rule When selecting
films do they demonstrate freedom of
thinking freedom of speech do they act
within a legal framework leaving
audiences to decide whether they can
separate the art from the artist Charlie
Angela Al Jazeera cam
football now and Manchester City will
play into